Turns
out he was murdered by this crazy man.
That crazy man
was traveling with a little girl.
James, lower the gun.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
This will be my Full Last of Us
Episode eight Video.
There were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references to the game,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand into the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes here for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet,
but we'll start at the beginning
and work our way through shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs
wtf moments in there were many.
This was probably the most WTF episode
of the series and it was planned that way
because it was pretty much
the way it went down the games.
You're meant to be horrified
by a lot of the things that David does.
He's meant to be like
one of the worst villains,
if not the worst villain that you meet
during the events of the first game.
You're meant to feel like he's worse
than the cordyceps fungus.
He even talks about the fungus
as if it is a god.
Eddie worships it
like you would worship the biblical God.
That's how nutters he's meant to be.
He is totally crazy.
The title of the episode is When We Are In
Need, which is a reference to Ellie's
fight with David's group in the prayer
that they have written on their banner.
When we are in need,
he shall provide like their group treats
Ellie as if she was sent by God
to answer their prayers for food
and her getting the medicine from them
and being able to save Joel's life.
Technically, she's saved herself.
At the end of the episode,
Joel helped a lot,
like he definitely helped
by getting rid of a lot
of their dangerous members of the group.
But I think part of the idea is that
had Ellie not gotten that penicillin,
the medicine from them,
Joel would have died.
So in a way,
they want to make you question like, oh,
maybe there was some faith aspect to this.
Like maybe there was some higher power.
But in the games,
David's group is effectively referred to
by the fans as the cannibals.
They did add a bunch of material
that wasn't in the games
just to round out the backstory.
Their group give you a better vibe
for the rest of the people in his group.
Not all of them are meant to be terrible.
Like as they explain.
Some of the people like the little girl
here doesn't understand
that she winds up eating her father.
Basically, the meat there definitely
does not look or taste like venison,
but some of the members of the group
have to know what's really going
on, what they're really doing.
And some do not know
with most of the group thinking of them
is has benevolent pastor
trying to help them through this difficult
time in the apocalypse
helped them survive using religion
when really he is more like a cult leader
the way that Ellie calls it.
He even admits that to like, Well,
you got me there.
This is some weird cult thing.
Uh, well,
you sort of kind of got me there.
The actual opening
scene is of David's group with him
reading from the Bible Revelations 21,
and they use it in the episode
as a metaphor
for the fungus in general, the apocalypse
and God cleansing the earth.
But David later reveals
that he'd been worshiping the fungus
itself, the cordyceps fungus,
this whole time.
So really,
when he's reading from this verse,
David said, he's read it to them
many times over and over again.
He's really been talking
about how the fungus is going to wipe
the earth clean
and create this new paradise.
But at the beginning of the episode,
they want to make
you think that it's
just a rallying cry for their group
because it's winter,
there isn't enough food.
People are starting to go hungry, and
most of them have lost hope of survival.
But even if you haven't played the game,
you're meant to get this really weird vibe
from David's character.
Like he just seems so creepy.
So they were trying to hide the fact
that something really sinister was going
on, and it's meant to pay off That earlier
quote from Joel a couple of episodes ago
where he told Ellie, No, you need to be
more worried about actual people out here.
The fungus. Yes. It's a dangerous thing.
You need to watch out for the infected.
But really, the danger out here is actual
people.
People are worse than the fungus
in the wilderness here
in David is meant to be like
the worst version of that.
After this scene, I also couldn't
stop thinking about that old Simpsons
sideshow Bob joke where he tricks everyone
into thinking that he's totally reformed
and all peaceful.
But really deep down, he just wants
revenge against Bart Simpson.
No, that's German for the BART. The
No. One
who speaks German could be an evil man.
Some of you may have picked up
on this earlier,
but the whole idea, as David explains
later when he's revealing the truth
about his back story to Ellie,
is that he was always sick and twisted.
He's always had a violent nature
in the fungus, the apocalypse.
The last 20 years just allowed him
a way to let that all out like it
gave him excuses
to express his diabolical tendencies.
And he used to be a math teacher.
So you wonder if he actually used to prey
on little kids like this when
he was a math teacher, he basically said
he's been this way the whole time.
Like all the worst things
you've ever heard priests being arrest for
or charged with, that's David.
And he is legitimately occult leader
at this point.
The way that their group operates like
is that Ellie calls it pretty accurately
at the beginning of the episode.
It also seems like during the episode
characters like James, played by Troy
Baker, big video game cameo.
I'll talk about him more in a second.
It seems like other people kind of know
what's really going on with him
and either turned a blind eye
or they wind up dying themselves
and being turned into food
like that's their option.
Either we tell you what's really going on
and you go along with it
or you become our next meal.
Once you actually seen the episode,
you go back and watch it again.
Every time you see him
talking to younger characters
like these little girls here,
it just makes it so much creepier.
The little girl's father
that they're waiting to spring to bury
is meant to be one of the people.
Jordan Ellie kills the university
as he reveals later in.
They also reveal he was lying.
He wasn't waiting to bury him till spring.
The ground is meant to be frozen,
but they're not wanting to bury him
was because
they were going to chop him up into food.
Like we can't bury the body
because we need the body.
The whole weird vibe
between James and David's
character is just meant to show you
that even though James definitely knows
what's really going on, like, we're
definitely going around eating people.
Most of the members of their group
are just doing what they can to survive
and feel incredibly remorseful about it.
It's only David who's meant to come off
being the truly
evil person in the episode.
Like everyone's doing terrible things.
But David is the truly evil one.
If you didn't recognize him right away.
James is played by Troy Baker, who does
the voice of Joel in the video games.
He will come back and do Joel again
if they do more scenes with him
during Last of Us 3.
No spoilers about how that would go down
because they have to use it
in a really creative way.
I don't mean to question
your sense of mercy, David.
We can let it go.
We bring that girl back with us.
She's just another mouth to feed.
Here's how this thing's going to play out.
You don't bring up Tess ever.
In fact,
we just keep our history to ourselves.
But they said one of the reasons
why Troy Baker didn't wind up playing
the TV show version of Joel instead of
Pedro Pascal, because Troy Baker is
a good actor is mostly because of his
look in the vibe of him just in general.
The showrunner
and Neil Druckmann said that in real life,
Troy Baker is kind of like this
really tall, very hippie
like character, just like very Jill,
very much not like Joel at all.
And Pedro Pascal
just did a much better job of portraying
Joel on screen, like live action.
Joel But I do think that Troy Baker
did a great job in this episode,
so maybe we'll see him popping up
in more live action stuff after this.
That would be funny
if he came back in season
two as a completely different character.
Like, Wait a minute,
you look kind of familiar.
Ellie continues to nurse Joel
back to health, slowly Feeding him in
the next part is right out of the game.
She goes out hunting for food.
The minor differences here is
that she was using a bow in the games
and she's using a rifle here.
Maybe they'll give her the bow.
In season two.
The rabbit also ran out of the game.
That's where the meme came from,
except on the show
she fails to kill it in a huge face plant.
But the deer is pretty accurate
to the games in the way
she winds up running into David and James.
She winds up wounding it
and then following it to the area
where David and James are, where they find
the deer and then Ellie finds them.
Any sudden moves, they put him right
between your eyes.
Ditto for buddy boy. Any sudden moves?
I put one right between your eyes.
Ditto for Buddy boy over there.
What do you want?
Names, David?
This here's my friend James.
What do you need?
Weapons, ammo, clothes, medicine.
We can trade you
for some of the gear we have.
What do you need? We have boots. Madison.
One of the minor differences, though,
in their interaction here,
even though a lot of the dialog
is similar to the games,
is that the TV
show version of David comes off
feeling so much more nice at the beginning
so that the turn later in the episode,
like the twist to him
revealing his true evil nature, winds up
being way more impactful in the games.
David was played by Nolan North,
who did a fantastic performance.
Nolan North is amazing.
How did you put it?
Tiny Pieces.
Tiny little pieces.
But when you meet David in the games,
he just comes off feeling more creepy
at the beginning.
So it's not as big of a surprise later
when you find out,
Oh yeah, he's
definitely creepy and wants to kill us.
So in the TV show,
David actually wound up delivering
an even better version of the performance.
Like the person whose truly evil
but hides under a mask of goodness
when he tells James to go back
and get the medicine that Ellie asked for
and trade.
The reason why he's confused
why James is confused
is because they barely have any supplies
as it is, and he doesn't want to give away
critical medicine.
He also has a similar conversation later
when he tells David
like, look,
we should not bring this girl back.
She's going to be in other mouth to feed.
It'll just be bad for all of us.
They make it seem like
James is starting to figure out
or he already knows
what's really going on with David.
Like, Oh,
you are definitely bad in
maybe he was trying
to do something about it and just couldn't
bring himself to do it, like couldn't
bring himself to act.
You rebel against him.
So as
bad as James came off in the episode,
like he tried to kill Ellie and advocated
for killing her many times,
that was the more merciful
of the two options to Ellie,
because David has far worse things
planned for her turning Ellie
into his own personal plaything.
You notice during their initial
exchange here how much Ellie is learned.
She discharges all the bullets
from their rifles, which is a smart move.
The scenes right after this with Ellie
and David alone together, also similar
to the game where initially
she must trust him correctly,
but he slowly starts to wear her down
with his false kindness,
lulling her into a false sense of security
until he reveals the truth
that he's figured out who they really are.
And they're the ones that killed
the members of their group back
at the university.
That turn is also right
out of the games, too.
He also mentions that he was from
the Pittsburgh quarantine zone originally
and it was destroyed in 2017,
which would have been about six years ago.
They also referenced the Pittsburgh
quarantines zone earlier on the show,
but it has a much bigger connection
to the plot in the games
because the TV show actually swapped
Pittsburgh in the games with the Hunters
for Kansas City in the games,
Joel and Ellie wind up
encountering the hunters, Sam
and Henry's character inside Pittsburgh.
But they just changed out to Kansas City
On the show.
David claims that he fled the Pittsburgh
quarantine zone with a few others.
They slowly traveled to this area
where they are now
evading raiders along the way,
picking up new people along the way.
And I think they want David's
groups turned to cannibalism
to be a parallel for what happened to Joel
when he joined the Hunters
on his way to the Boston Quarantine.
So, like all the terrible stuff
that Joel and Tommy felt
very remorseful about, what they'd done,
Dave is meant to be the darker
mirror of that.
Like he's not sorry about what
they've turned to, what they've done.
When he tries to convince Ellie
that destiny is a real thing,
like he's been praying to,
what we think is
God that he
later reveals is actually the court is
this fungus is meant to be a callback
to the Bible quote from their banter,
like he's really trying to say that
they're running into Ellie in the Dead
Deer was a gift from God or the fungus
because he's been worshiping the fungus,
asking he shall receive,
he shall provide in your time of need.
Suddenly they find the dead deer
waiting for them to eat,
which they'd been hunting
for specifically.
And a little girl who David had wanted
to find this whole time.
He'd been praying to the fungus
that he would find someone
like Ellie James returns, trapping Ellie.
The reason, again
that David wants to give her
the medicine is to lure her
into a false sense of security.
Because at least at first, he wants to
win her over with his kindness.
As sinister as it is.
Also, this is near their area.
David knows that this town is here,
so he thinks they'll be able to find Joel
pretty easily.
So he's not that worried about that part.
Then things really turn in the episode.
Things really get bad when they show
the scene of the group preparing a meal.
It's meant to allude to their cannibalism.
If you haven't played the games,
you might've suspected
something was weird about this.
But later when they bring in the deer
after the fact,
after they say that it was venison,
that's meant to be the confirmation
of what was really happening here
when they were preparing the meat.
So the idea here is that this woman lost
her husband, the little girl's father.
They needed food.
She brings in the cans
As we're running out, we barely have any.
Where does this meat come from in the guy
lives and says that it's venison.
Really?
This is her dead husband
that they just chopped up.
As they finish preparing the meal,
everyone grabs their portion
and starts to eat.
The little girl is basically eating her
father and the woman, her dead husband.
You also notice how when the little girl
screams for him to kill Ellie
and David, the music turns really dark
as he slaps her.
He also orders her to think of him
as her father, which is kind of the vibe
of what happens with Ellie later.
You start to worry about what
he's going to do to this little girl.
Eventually to it, his true
nature starts to show even more.
The reason why he reacted that way is
because he does plan to keep Ellie alive.
As we find out later in the episode.
Four Terrible Things.
And when he says
bring Joel to justice, he's basically
saying, we're going to turn Joel
into our next meal
right after he says the prayer
and they start eating the food.
He's basically
the only one with a smile on his face
as they're eating the woman's dead husband
and her father, and he's sitting
right in front of them knowing full
well exactly what's happening.
That's how evil he's meant to be.
This is like right out of the South Park
episode where Eric Cartman fed
the kid his dead father.
You like it?
Do you like it?
Should I cut it, Mr. and Mrs.
Tenement kiddy.
As Ellie feeds their horror,
she learns that David's group
has returned to try and capture them.
She tries to lead them
away, leaving Joel with his knife.
James takes out the horrors R.I.P.
He was a good horse in the fall, renders
her unconscious and easy for David
to haul back to his makeshift prison.
But you remember the whole thing here.
Troy Baker James character trying to kill
her would almost have been a mercy.
Like getting rid of her early
would have been the better option for her
just because what David had planned for
her was so much worse.
So as bad as James is in the episode,
as bad as Troy Baker's character was,
he was the better of the two options.
The others go looking for Joel
and he has a huge rally moment
choking out and killing all the members.
They're eventually
torturing a couple of them,
which is also right out of the games.
He goes for Liam Neeson on both of them.
I'm a man with a particular set of skills
looking for a daughter.
There were a lot of people
that expected this
because they played the games and were
hoping that he'd be interrogating James
so that you'd have like a Joel versus Joel
kind of moment.
But obviously the showrunner,
the producers
didn't want to be that on the nose
with it.
Like, Well,
the two Joel's meet each other on screen.
Nope, turns out not.
Ellie wakes up in David's
prison cell in the butcher room
where they butcher people.
It's right out of the games
where she slowly starts
to learn about David's true
nature and his plans for her.
She sees the ear discovering
the truth, like, Oh, you plan on
chopping us up into little bits.
And David tries to argue the finer points
of morality with her in the apocalypse
and justifying his actions
by saying he's doing all this to save
everyone in his group is no different
than Joel killing people to save you.
He confirms
that he's always been violent like this
and he senses the violence in Ellie,
which is a thing like Neal Druckmann,
the showrunner, did say that
Ellie is meant to have violent tendencies,
and being with Joel
has brought that out of her.
But her time with Joel has made
both of them better people, whereas David
is made to go in the opposite direction
like it only makes him more evil.
And he's just gotten
very good at hiding his true nature
beneath his mask of serenity and goodness
in the apocalypse.
Like you thought, eating people
and torturing little girls was bad.
He also believes that the fungus is a God
that should be worshiped.
That's how crazy he's meant to be.
The whole vibe of David's character
in the games is very similar to this.
Like I said, Nolan North did a great job
of pulling off this turn where he goes
even crazier later in this adventure.
You have no idea.
But I think the TV show version of David
takes it like that extra mile,
like he goes extra crazy in the episode.
And I love the way
that they cut the tension
in this next moment
to where just for a brief hot second,
they want to make you wonder
if Ellie is willing to sacrifice herself
in order to save Joel leg if she joins
David willingly, he'll spare their lives,
even though it's probably a lie.
He probably won't of killing Joel
no matter what.
But she winds up using the opportunity
to break his finger
and trying to escape again,
which is classic Ellie.
He'll know
she's not going to be his child bride.
Somebody get Chris Hansen on the phone.
Is he still alive in the apocalypse?
We need some help here To Catch
a Predator, The Last of Us edition.
Most of the end of the episode
is similar to the games
to where Joel winds up
arriving at the town to help save her.
But Ellie also winds up saving herself.
It's meant to be a team effort
like Joel took out a bunch of their group
before he arrived, making it
a little bit easier for her to escape.
He winds up finding her backpack,
the dead deer
and a bunch of dead human bodies
waiting to be butchered,
confirming everyone's
fears and suspicions during the episode.
Like, Oh yeah, they're definitely chopping
people up to eat them.
Every time David has lamented
and said prayers over the dead,
members of their group really is them
just chopping them up for food?
You wonder how
some of those people died too.
Like were they killed on purpose
or did they die by accident?
Ellie trying to use her condition
to save herself.
The infection is also out of the games.
R.I.P. to Troy Baker.
She winds up killing James
when she escapes.
Then when she lights
the fire in the lodge.
That's meant to be a big biblical metaphor
for the devil.
Like David
is meant to feel like the biblical devil
because of what he's trying to do,
how evil he is.
And they want to make the room feel
kind of like it's hell burning for a brief
hot second, Ellie is trapped
in metaphorical hell with the devil.
Just before she escapes, he references
becoming her creepy dad, teaching
her, quote unquote,
just like he told the other little girl
at the beginning of the episode, showing
the depths of his depravity in
after stabbing the hell out of him.
Better
make sure better double tap that corpse.
She breaks out and finds Joel
with both of them just breaking down
completely.
And Joel referring to her
as baby girl like a dad.
Wood So this is really meant
to be a moment
that crystallizes their relationship
the trauma that they both
just went through.
He openly acknowledges her like a dad.
Wood his daughter,
and she thinks of him as a father figure.
PIPER Bless now let's get out of here.
Overall, even though it felt like
a quick episode, it was great TV show.
David Like I said, so much creepier
than the video game.
David Even though Noah North's
performance in the game is also great,
if you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the episode
that I didn't mention in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
Next week.
Episode nine is meant to be the finale.
I will do an Episode nine trailer video
and they will be covering
the rest of the plot from the first game.
So even if it feels like a speed run,
there is still a lot of plot to cover.
Like a lot of really big twists
and turns in the finale,
even though the episode itself
is meant to be relatively short next week,
they've already confirmed season
two and Season two
will adapt the first half of the plot,
at least maybe a little bit
less than that of the first game.
They could even break the second game
into three different seasons
if they wanted to.
Then just because there's
so much more plot
that actually happens in the second game
than the first game.
The first game is much shorter
in runtime than the second game.
My full episode time video will post
next week after they release it.
And big reminder
to talk about Pedro Pascal in the pascal-verse
the Mandalorian Season
3 episodes have started
My Full Mandalorian Season three Episode
two video will also post this week.
On Wednesday.
Everyone click here for that last of us
Episode 9 Video.
Update the link
as soon as I posted and click here
for all my Mandalorian Season
three episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe and this is the way.